[Music]
christian
in miami florida how can we help you
hey guys thank you so much for taking my
call um
been listening to you guys all year
non-stop every day
um catching up on old like episodes and
everything so really grateful me and my
husband are really grateful for
everything that you guys do as a team
they're amazing well thank you so
really quick on on our and so we started
this year
with the program um i want to say at the
beginning of the year but you know the
first month is always a little difficult
so we started in february like full on
and um so i started doing
you know how dave always says like
deliver pizza deliver this
and do as much as you can yes so i
started doing a door dash
and um getting a few like 50
maybe a night depends on depending
on the day after that i started doing
a few like balloon decoration stuff
and um that kind of started taking off
on its own and uh right now we're
we actually even have like um uh storage
for things because it's gotten to a
point where we can't hold it anymore at
the house
and um we're looking into even buying a
car
and we're in baby step two so my
question was
uh we are so
like i said we started this year we just
paid off already like 17k
in in debt like credit cards we just
paid off our car
great and um we're we're going to we're
working on student loans where
we we have a long way 151 000
in student loans we both went to private
school for
art and um we're working hard to try to
get rid of it um so
uh the business my side of the business
is taking off and
we're thinking of getting an suv because
we have a nissan altima
and there we like have grass laws and
a bunch of balloons that we have to
deliver sometimes and
it just doesn't fit in there sometimes
we have to take
another car or rent a car right so
my question was if if it's a smart idea
to put the money that we've been putting
aside for that
into a car or into the student loans
that we have planned already to
pay right now we have we do have an
emergency fund that we don't touch
and we have six thousand dollars to save
the side
for a car um we know we're not getting a
brand new car
we just need to get a bigger car
christian are you are you talking about
are you talking about getting another
car or are you talking about selling the
nissan
and just getting a van
and you use for your van for your
personal and business
what are you talking about doing having
two cars it's still just one car
well we're we're kind of looking at both
right now
um we've gotten a quote for our car from
carvana
and they're offering uh twelve thousand
dollars for it the 2008.
okay not bad um how much do you owe on
it
you say you just paid it off okay we
just paid it off last month
what does kelly boob look say the value
of your car is worth if you privately
sell it
oh i'm not sure okay so that's gonna
have to
look that up yeah so that's the very
first thing i'm doing i'm going to
kbb.com i'm going to look up the
trade-in value plus the private
private sale value um i am not a fan
okay i am not a fan of two things one
you have uh six thousand dollars in your
savings account now you say you're
saving that for a card for your business
uh okay a little bit there here's what
i'm gonna recommend
your debt paying off your debt is your
number one priority number two if you
wanna sell your car
okay sell your nissan and take that and
maybe add on a couple of grand
so you can get a van i have no problem
with that
but what i do not want you to do is to
keep your nissan and
also just wipe out all your money that
could have went towards the debt
to buy a second car yeah hey christian
watch sayo
how often is it that you have to pack
the grass walls or fences whatever you
said you had
it could it could be every other week
like example next week we're both friday
saturday and sunday and
it it comes and goes right now like if i
look at
profit-wise like there's months that we
could be
booked completely every weekend and
there's months that we are booked every
other weekend
right and you said right now as you bump
into that scenario if it's needed
you you rent a car yes
yeah ao keeps saying van yeah ao keeps
saying van
you never uttered the word van you said
suv
didn't you yes and that means expensive
uv okay how much are you talking about
spending
you quit chuckling i knew i was
listening to you how much you thinking
about spending
um well i was looking at a 2017.
no stop right there
you need to start with a 19 something
you're looking for a 1999 astro vapor
wait a minute with wood pan hunch your
mouth i'm just playing
christian here's the deal here's the
deal i love that you guys are hustling i
really do
i like that you're making stuff happen
but here's what i want you to make
happen
i want you to make this debt shrink you
follow me
my concern is is an aoes hit the nail on
the head and talk about if you can sell
your car for 12
i'd much rather you go find a 10 000
suv something that you can you can run
into the ground and hustle i just think
whenever i start to talk to
self-employed people especially like you
like you're a salesperson i can tell
okay i really can't i think you you you
could sell me some suntan lotion
i really do i feel like you could i feel
like you could but i got my a game on
but i think people that are
self-employed they'll always be able to
rationalize
doing something else right like being
able to divert from the plan so
christian i want you to do this i want
you and your husband to sit down and
talk
i want you guys to look at this
situation and say hey what's in the best
interest of our family
like if we're being real not like like
straight up like if we're trying to make
sure we're moving in a direction as a
family
for the sake of our kids for the sake of
our business what's the smartest play
for us to do
not the preference not what you like but
what's the smart thing
and i think looking at it through that
lens where you go hey if we do this
and we get this suv now we're going to
move forward we're not rationalizing
buying anything else
we're going to stay plugged into this
and we're going to attack this debt
the beauty of being self-employed is you
don't have caps on your income
there's nobody giving you a limit saying
hey that's all you can make
you get an opportunity to take the sky
to the limit and so that's what i want
you guys to do i want you to make this
decision together
looking at it being intentional and say
hey let's make a two-year decision
i want to make a decision now that i'm
going to look back on in two years and i
go
boy i'm glad i made that i'm glad i was
uncomfortable for a little while so i
can be
effective later it's a difference you
can do it christian and we're here on
your side
this is the dave ramsey show